call of duty black ops cold war
premiered their first zombies trailer
there's a lot to unpack here so let's
get into everything we know so far
starting from the very beginning in
2008's call of duty world at war
the first ever zombie experience was a
little map called noctur untoten
also known as knight of the undead it
was a humble start to what is now one of
the biggest game modes in call of duty
history
in black ops cold war the zombie story
picks up 40 years later from that very
same night
while on the run samantha maxis sends a
videotape to gregory weaver with
evidence of a zombie outbreak from 40
years ago
in the footage we see the underground
bunker where the experiments using d
machine first took place not only did it
actually happen but it was almost
covered up entirely by the german
military
after containing what they could of the
outbreak the germans are seen torching
piles of zombies and sealing off the
underground bunker
before weaver can convince samantha to
turn herself in for protection
she explains that the bunker has been
reopened and that the rival omega group
is planning more outbreaks
to stop the omega group's plans weaver
leads a newly formed team called
requiem to investigate and contain any
threats in the bunker
from the trailer it appears that
nocturne toten was only a small part of
the base where the experiments were held
the expanded map will feature new areas
including the lab itself
and a large outdoor area in between also
seen are a mix of new and old perk
machines ranging from juggernog and
quick revive to an all-new perk called
elemental pop
we also see the return of the mystery
box pack-a-punch machines and wonder
weapons as well as some updated enemies
including disgusting new hellhounds
radioactive zombies
and this larger zombie in a full
radiation suit who appears to have some
abilities of his own
speaking of abilities a support slot is
making its way into zombies
alongside your tactical and lethal
equipment you'll have a support slot
that can carry larger score streak style
pickups like a chopper gunner
which is huge also if we slow down this
part it looks like equipment or even
special equipment can now be dropped by
zombies in the same way that they drop
nukes and max ammos
introduced for the first time in zombies
mode is the ability to end a match
designer kevin drew explains that
players can now complete a zombie
session
at the cost of playing a few more
intense rounds of zombies first
if you complete these tougher rounds
you'll get to x-fil safely and call it a
day
other big news includes weapon
progression carryover
in previous black ops games zombies mode
had its own progression and prestige
system
and leveling up in zombies wouldn't
carry over into multiplayer
say goodbye to that lastly what's a
zombie's mode without its secrets
lead writer craig houston explained that
there will be a lot of intel to uncover
so much so that they've introduced a new
intel system that catalogs the
information you've acquired
making it simpler to put the pieces of
the puzzle together the requiem team
isn't the only team after the bunker
secrets we're warned that not everyone
is trustworthy and that all of this
intel will reveal all of the terrifying
secrets about the events that took place
decades ago
let's keep the conversation going in the
comments if you noticed something else
cool in the trailer or are just hyped to
play nocturnal toten again
let us know thanks for watching
[Music]